we'll see when the [ __ ] it's Wednesday
night show you guys a special [ __ ]
around the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by myself maybe put me in the closet
[ __ ] jack is Wednesday night you better
recognize [ __ ] you on fire you on
fire before you break a gram and she
says
[Music]
like she said what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here in full
[ __ ] but why I'm saying it's that
nitrogen I said quoi if you're under 18
get the [ __ ] out of here
I don't want your young [ __ ] go
back to breach school you [ __ ] it's the
real deal here tonight please if I open
up and show you like Joey you didn't
open up a show with a bung it no need to
my co-host an executive Goomba Lisa at
that he is he's real way this [ __ ] my
collection big spot green is never spot
like five minutes let's give up on a
death here
I borrow bomb like that
[Music]
give me two minutes we [ __ ] around so
that you understand me I went down
economy school we got a bunch of little
treats for you [ __ ] we relaxed
already
drink some water we wait I know what you
need you need to start messaging me
listen when you're coughing you can't
stop clapping our star of death I'll do
the trick
no hesitate you gotta measure it like
[ __ ] night look just do it there you
go two of those things we'll take care
of that draw we'll take care of that
clock tip time ago
nothing's in the night don't say right
looks like I'm gonna be up all night you
dare enter this [ __ ] house just
like that look me
[Music]
you'll need no [ __ ] water I could
drink these on an island solo like
Gilligan understand me Gilligan can suck
my dick
I could just eat stars on the island of
death this [ __ ] bingo that's the end of
the [ __ ] purple ones we're gonna eat
a whole bag of red ones to make the
minimum team we just killed the back but
we have been tapping into it the whole
week I'm saying one other day who gives
a [ __ ] that's right
we don't live we don't do regular weeks
here we do - wait dude a week's here
right all I know is Monday and Wednesday
the rest I leave up to you look we got
for you people tonight we got goodies
come on you're gonna learn something oh
[Music]
we got it you're sitting there going
uncle Joey what do you got in there let
me show you the [ __ ]
[Music]
first of all monolith business music
[ __ ] wrapping paper we got a little
[ __ ] terror move a little [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] just to show you
[ __ ] how we're living here you
got these things these saline post these
they're like little choice for [ __ ] when
you have a Tuesday night but who gives a
[ __ ] I ain't smoking again I'm saying
then you got this little [ __ ]
collection here for yourself [ __ ]
fuels for the head that's right we don't
[ __ ] around here legally that for this
so you over that giggling thinking this
is a joke this you got no escape look at
this we got so lean what's this thousand
milligrams premium canopy concentrate oh
[ __ ] somebody's dying tonight look at
this thing right here look at this this
is called let me show you [ __ ]
what you're missing all right don't
worry about the shields I'm gonna pull
effect this is blackjack I know a black
dude named blackjack one time is missing
it on check this out oh my goodness oh
my look at this what the [ __ ] you think
it'd be a little bit less you understand
me this collided this way this three
beat you could turn all the lights off
in your [ __ ] house welcome on the
house with this thing this is blackjack
my main man Gino from Speedway gave me
this box and this is also Saleem coastal
grown marijuana here for you
[ __ ] alright you want to see
the deadly on the semen uncle Joey
this one here is blue dream let me show
you these Nuggets a [ __ ] wreath a look
at this oh my goodness we each gonna
smoke on this abundantly just one nugget
of Ultima look at that understand me
we're [ __ ] around will tell your
friends
get a little snaps I can run away from
home walk to the [ __ ] train station
suck a little digging you're on the
train to [ __ ] oh look at this one oh
[ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] beauty nest right
here this would they give the [ __ ] oh
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] nugget of death
look at this look at this you put the
ciass won't get on the plane forget
about it who gives a [ __ ] if they throw
you off the seat you don't say we got a
vapor pack
look at this this is what we're smoking
tonight this is rocks
we put this in you [ __ ] and we wait
for [ __ ] three weeks we got we got
utensils we're waiting people we
understand but we're doing it right here
we [ __ ] around and we got an ashtray
of look what is the [ __ ] definitely
understand me look at that and it
doubles as a [ __ ] weapon so I see you
lurking around here I'll throw a [ __ ]
weapon that [ __ ] and we got one hundred
milligram medicated this is our each I
must eat this right now okay who's
counting
only little [ __ ] micro dose count
milligrams we [ __ ] go by sound did we
stop when somebody dies all right
break up the [ __ ] nothing
right a medication waiting around
look what else they gave me a little
wheat dragon look at this this is not a
respectful poorly sure we still gotta
have a [ __ ] Saturday night whatever
it is Wednesday night
who said bond it oh [ __ ] with some of
this moon rock I always look was just
[ __ ] walked in this [ __ ] moon
Esther ku the Korean missile direct they
sent the direct from [ __ ] Korea this
Korea's number one weapon right watch
out watch out you look dirty oh [ __ ]
[Music]
that's the [ __ ] point let me get that
cleaner over there dirty [ __ ] Joey the
dome of day how was your day today you
look beautiful bond it's been good all
day can you believe that what am I
trying to do here be a poster child for
anyway
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you guys call them from
listen I lower your plans off but if
you're under 14 18 hang up mount that's
the cool is here we don't want no
[ __ ] misunderstanding we this one's
for you it's gonna happen to you do the
same shut the easily app the eye ball
flies idea at that type of [ __ ] no sir I
feel like let's do it this is our
respect for Israel this for the [ __ ]
in the army you don't say no more
[ __ ] in the army with the [ __ ]
that's the secret weapon if you want to
come here it's when you want you more
than welcome that's right
[Music]
I told you that's the one that's the way
[Music]
[Music]
now let's do this [ __ ] was ready for
fondant it was that's the coolest [ __ ]
by the time we get through with you
you'll be speaking Korean tonight we'll
be all over TV miles letters
you're not doing 92 sitting there with a
thumb up your ass what do you have to
complain it what taking the journey you
know why cuz we love you we love you
like [ __ ] just like that just
like that cuz we said something we never
want to take you anywhere
oh [ __ ] you want some stars for Mom why
not we'll give her a little rise
[Music]
take get two of these what is it that
you don't care
big or sickle
[Music]
what's your mind don't you mind got your
mind so anyway that's it and that's not
the book God has sold down to the last
they [ __ ] did kinky things we'll get
to it later and that's sadly you're at
the [ __ ] who's there at the Comedy
Store and Saturday night at the I sounds
like sweet working out what uncle Joey
that's completely different there's a
[ __ ]
we're here tonight because you're not
the what do you know watch Dancing with
the Stars some bachelorette show
somebody's singing karaoke you gives a
[ __ ] this is live TV [ __ ] coming
at your periscope that's the cool you
ready to go it's our life is gonna win
she's gonna wait
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] on the roller skates
Cathy Oh
[Music]
as the cool don't last ago it's
Wednesday night in this [ __ ] hit
Alaska cool blow that smoke up these
[ __ ] let them know the careers of
back [ __ ]
[Music]
it's that type of night you wander you
got understanding some [ __ ] podcast
on the thing some are crazy
every week we give you some different
[ __ ] flip you don't walk right here
remember what the [ __ ] I knew this would
come back these people doing things
leave ready for another bond get away
[Music]
listen youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
that's what this [ __ ] same thing is
going understand me
are you ready to rock what do you want
to do here you want to [ __ ] it
youtube.com slash see that Joey Diaz
[Music]
that's right that's right [ __ ] so
get it together
we got nothing going on trumped on 100gb
theory on me you gotta get your [ __ ]
together and look up for yourself the
voice comes over and you read hummus
sports you follow me see right now
you're eating hummus for you look hi I
love wave to your [ __ ] feet looking
around they're smacking in the face Isis
Isis this Bobcat Lowe's Felicia your
tight jeans on push it over [ __ ]
Mexican guys try the sell fruit on the
corner don't puss those fruit people
they can tell if you looked around the
last two years the fruit Mexican fruit
business has doubled its six months away
from being legal but the Mexican fruit
business the stands have doubled and
they also have nice umbrellas they have
multicolored umbrellas so you can see
that they're all one person that my
slide squeezes but 20 years ago you
don't remember there was a thing on
Sunset called storm maps and what it
really was a little prostitution ring
but nobody thought it was they was just
on the side of the sunset star map star
maps
there was 16 year olds who column Inc
for a [ __ ] they found that years
later so now everybody sees these
[ __ ] Mexicans selling fruits is [ __ ]
then I've selling fruit
those are cartel drop-off points so on
the way back to Mexico listen they send
the fruit up with the coke in it then
they give the fruit to their people it's
brilliant you don't lose what a [ __ ]
thank you for help
what a [ __ ] you people think you're
dealing with some [ __ ] Junior Olympic
it nobody figured that out until I told
them just so people know what the [ __ ]
is crack-a-lackin' in their neighborhood
so when you see three Mexican vendors
they all got the same fruity colored
umbrellas met four blocks away that's
why
you don't have the umbrella
he's got the white umbrella you don't
have the multi color umbrella if you've
noticed they have the ones with the
white umbrella and the ones with the
multi-color umbrella next to each other
so ones one cartel family and the other
ones another cartel family so what
you're basically doing you don't know
they send the fruit up in the
watermelons so every time you [ __ ]
Mexican to take the sour this is a
cocaine on the neck [ __ ] days all
those Mexican dudes so on the way up
the coke is in the fruit smuggled in the
fruit think that they don't suck they
don't lose on the fruit they sell in the
coke is already distributed all they're
doing this drop-off points the cash so
on certain days certain them every week
it changes so Tuesdays this guy might
get a collect so it's on the way down to
Mexico I'm just picking up cash we drop
it off on a warehouse in San Diego they
load and they take that [ __ ] right back
into San Diego there's the [ __ ]
lesson for y'all periscope nobody tells
you this [ __ ] you know why there's
nobody to figure that [ __ ] out who else
is gonna figure this [ __ ] out of uncle
Joey you here for you who the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with youtube.com
slash c / joey beers that's the place to
be [ __ ] Joey Diaz tune into the
church or what's happening now we about
to get started
Lisa how's your pee guys I love you
[ __ ] feelin